- If you look everywhere around you,
it's kinda what James Brown said,
is that "Every piece of music after him
"you could hear a little
bit 'a James Brown."
That's, like, Black History in a nutshell.
(whoosh)
(swish)
(creak)
(emotional piano music)
- And I think black
history is so important
because it's kind of your
time to be celebrated.
- There should be a
month where we celebrate
amazing leaders that fought
for freedom for everybody.
- It gives a more complete picture
of the history of the United States.
- Black History Month
means people can overcome
a lot of sad, oppressive
things and come out
being big and beautiful
and shine right through.
- It's a story about civil disobedience.
It's about people grabbing power.
- The first book I ever
read where I was like,
I relate to this so much, was
Black Boy by Richard Wright.
It was about poverty, and struggle,
and tryin' to overcome obstacles,
and that was the first
time I was like "Wow."
- Learning about hip-hop when I was young,
graffiti, MCing, DJing, breaking.
Without that I wouldn't
be who I was today.
- Black folk in America
came over in ships.
Look at the way that you came in.
But you look at yourself
now and you're like,
whoa, we are fucking blowing up.
- Do I listen to those stories
and identify with them,
regardless of what color I am?
Yeah!
And I think it's important for
everyone to hear this stuff.
- I think of black leaders
such as Angela Davis.
I admire them, I read all their books.
- And Latinos, like,
we're crossing rivers,
and we're crossing borders,
and we're in the back
of cars, sometimes, to get here.
And it's almost like, whoa, look at them.
We can do it too.
- Just close your eyes,
and listen to the stories,
and you will relate because
they're American stories.
(swoosh)
(swish)
(whoosh)
(creak)